when the first human visits mars it will
be the biggest scientific breakthrough
since landing on the moon probably
bigger but what if i told you the cia
and united states military have already
been to mars but they didn't use
spaceships to get there
they used psychics let's find out why
[Music]
the cold war between the united states
and soviet union involved a lot more
than spy planes and secret agents the
two countries have spent billions on
some crazy projects
like the cia's operation acoustic kitty
okay i'll bite what the hell is an
acoustic kitty i'm glad you asked
acoustic kitty involved implanting a
microphone into a cat's ear canal and a
transmitter at the base of its skull and
its job was to listen in on two men
having a conversation in a park outside
a soviet compound in washington dc did
the cat hear anything just the sound of
a taxi horn no boy do you mean yep it
was hit by a car as soon as it was let
out of its cage ugh what did that little
experiment cost 20 million dollars and
one perfectly good cat
and the russians experimented with using
low frequency radio waves to control the
brains of dogs i didn't know dogs had
brains in 1972 a classified report was
circulating in the american intelligence
community the report claimed that the
soviet union was pouring millions into
programs to research esp mind reading
and telekinesis
all for the purpose of espionage this
made the cia nervous so they immediately
requested funding to develop their own
program to train psychic spies did they
get the funding
sorry stupid question later that year
the cia
u.s army and defense intelligence agency
set up secret facilities all over the
country and recruited people who claimed
to have esp and researchers were
specifically interested in people who
were skilled in remote viewing which is
exactly what it sounds like a psychic in
one location describes what they see in
another location and they actually found
people who could do this well in 1976 a
russian bomber went down in the congo
and the details of the crash were sent
to cia psychic researchers operating out
of patterson air base in ohio there a
psychic named rosemary smith drew maps
of the congo and pointed to a specific
place where she claimed the plane was
so a paramilitary unit was dispatched to
that location they found the plane they
found the plane whoa
the cia was convinced they were onto
something so the various psychic
projects going on around the country and
there were quite a few of them we're all
consolidated to fort meade in maryland
this became known as project stargate
and project stargate ran for years it
was finally shut down in 1995 after
nightline reported about it but in those
23 years
cia remote viewers were used in all
kinds of operations and they delivered
results remote viewers drew renderings
of secret soviet bases they located
hostages of the red brigade in italy and
victims of the israeli hostage crisis
they saw locations of scud missiles
during the first gulf war and a remote
viewer even saw the eventual attack of
the world trade center though his
warning was ignored in 1989 a remote
viewer named angela ford was asked to
help track a former customs agent who
was on the run and she told researchers
she was able to see him in lowell
wyoming was he low well there's actually
no such place as low wyoming oh but
there is a level wyoming which is only
one letter off and he was there he was
there you're blowing my mind so
researchers began to wonder if we can
use remote viewing to see places here on
earth can we use remote viewing to visit
other planets can we
well that brings us to the story of joe
mcmonagle who if you believe him is the
first person to ever visit mars
and the first person to ever travel back
in time
[Music]
joe mcmonagle was a u.s army
intelligence officer who served in
vietnam in 1970 he was seriously injured
in a helicopter accident and almost died
and when he recovered he realized he had
psychic powers and began working for
project stargate as a psychic spy
between 1978 and 1984 mcmonicle was
involved in 450 separate cia missions
that he helped locate hostages in iran
he once discovered a shortwave radio
hidden inside a kgb agent's calculator
but his strangest mission took place on
may 22nd 1984. here's how it went
mcmonagle was in a room with one other
person a researcher he was given a
sealed envelope and instructed not to
open it he was then given a set of
geographic coordinates and asked to
describe what he saw all right using the
information in the envelope please focus
on 40.89 degrees north
9.55 degrees west
uh
i want to say it looks like uh i don't
know it's
it sort of looks like
like pyramids it's very high okay
i'm seeing
it's like a perception of a shadow of
people very very tall thin
it's only shadow
it's as if they were there and they're
not
they're not there anymore go back to a
period of time where they are there
[Music]
it's like
i get a lot of static on the line and
everything it's
it's breaking up all the time it's just
it's very fragmentary pieces just report
the data don't try to put things
together just report the raw data
i just keep seeing very large people
they appear thin and tall but they're
very large
uh wearing some kind of strange clothes
he's then directed to explore other sets
of coordinates still with no other
information the mcmonagle describes
seeing a large obelisk that reminds him
of the washington monument he sees what
he describes as rounded bottom carved
channels like road beds he sees pyramids
that appear to be storm shelters and in
the pyramids more thin shadowy people
that seem to be hibernating he claims
these are an ancient people dying and
past their time or age after his visions
fade the envelope is torn open and on it
reads the planet mars time of interest
approximately 1 million years bc holy sh
now look some of these stories may sound
crazy but all the information we've
presented today comes from a cia
document dump about project stargate and
other psychic projects yeah but these
document dumps are always a little light
how many pages are we talking 25 50. 12
million
yep so you might not believe in psychics
or esp and that's fine but the united
states government absolutely does and
it's easy to marginalize someone like
joseph mcmonagle and call him a kook but
he was and is a serious guy he wasn't
reading tarot cards at a county fair
somewhere when he retired from the army
he was awarded the legion of merit for
outstanding service he's written books
given lectures he's been interviewed
countless times and he believes he was
part of a very important and effective
research project now of his hundreds of
missions they weren't all successful but
even being successful at remote viewing
one percent of the time is extraordinary
but according to the cia mcmonicle was
successful 20 of the time it's not like
anyone could just guess the location of
a sunken soviet typhoon class submarine
but joe mcmonicle was able to do it
if this was so effective why did the
government shut it down uh once the
government starts a program does it ever
really go away nope
project stargate was shut down in the
90s but that was by no means the end of
government research into esp in 2014 the
office of naval research launched a
four-year 4 million program to explore
the use of premonition or sixth sense
among sailors and marines and there are
others dr edwin may the former head of
the stargate project continues to say
esp is a legitimate tool for military
intelligence in the scientific community
the military intelligence organizations
and in the highest levels of government
there are plenty of people who support
research into the paranormal personally
i consider myself a skeptical believer
or an open-minded skeptic but i think
this is still a subject worthy of study
i mean open any congressional spending
bill and look at the junk in there we
spent 27 million dollars to teach people
in morocco how to create pottery three
million dollars to encourage chinese
prostitutes to drink responsibly oh i
hear a few congressmen supported that
one six hundred thousand dollars to
study why chimps throw their feces
i wish i could do that i'm glad you
can't so yeah if we can spend a million
dollars studying the effect of cocaine
on the sexual habits of quail
we can spend a few bucks on esp and look
at it this way as long as there's a cia
and as long as there's a united states
congress this channel will have plenty
of material are there any studies about
the effect of vodka on goldfish sex i
don't think so well let's start
researching baby
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share
defeating the youtube algorithm is
harder than locating the ancient
civilization on mars but together we can
do it until next time be safe be kind
know that you are appreciated
[Music]
you